foreign
hey what's up internet welcome back to
Mega bed it's been a few weeks since
we've been here I'm joined by my friend
Justin haywald hi hi uh Eli you're a
senior news editor I am I lead the news
desk here so I don't come on the show
that often but thanks for having me over
to play some old games yeah we're going
to be playing uh un Squadron today which
you've never played right no I I made
the joke that uh I played Rogue Squadron
and which this is not this is not this
is a Super Nintendo game I thought you
were I thought you were trying to do
something funny as well no I'm not funny
so the UN Squadron is apparently known
as 80 area 88 in Japan yeah based off an
old manga series they had a few I think
straight to video animation things in
Japan but yeah it's one of the first
Super Nintendo games come on America uh
it's by Capcom it's a side-scrolling
shooter it's pretty tough but it's kind
of forgiving like it's not the one hit
kill kind of shooter that a lot of
people are used to uh but yeah let's
let's jump into it I just shut off the
laptop so if there are questions that
you're putting in the twitch stream
we'll get to those shortly once the
computer reboots
it's called un Squadron I would guess
that stands for uh United Nations
Squadron I think so unless you can come
up with something more understandable
determine
I love watching these intro sequences
so good only a Madman would take all
this Mission lucky they found me
I'm crazy as hell you get a good crotch
shot there yeah
yeah it's got the
shaft also is this using mode seven is
that that's what it's called right yes
yeah
why are you shutting down laptop
so so this is so like it seems like it
would be kind of a first person shooter
like Flying Star Fox style but this is
just going to be side scrolling or yeah
uh the Flaming unicorn I don't I don't
know why the mascot of the UN yeah like
you do do you know why it's called area
88 uh area 88 is supposed to refer to a
location and then a country like in the
middle of a desert I I'm not actually
like familiar with everything I'm going
to turn this down to easy just for the
stream because it's hard to play and
stream at the same time and as you all
know I'm not very good at old video
games despite loving them
um yeah no I don't know why is area 88
specifically uh but yeah and as usual
you're playing this on the Retron five
yes uh playing this on the Retron five
uh we're gonna start giving away older
Retron systems on megabit in the next
couple weeks I met with the guys from
hyperkin and they are Keen to do that so
if you guys like to play old games uh
you might want to get one of those
systems so you have three characters to
choose from what are they all different
stats I would assume yeah I guess I just
chose Shin because I took too long all
right so we'll play Shin for a minute
um these are pretty standard character
at least relative to this game
um other characters you know they can
take different amounts of hits before
they their health starts to run out uh
so right now what I'm doing is I'm
picking a [__] a plane this is the
default one
uh yep now every shoot every ship that
you've uh shoot down in this game you're
in currency and you can earn weapons and
new armor I'm gonna get the bombs now
that I'm looking at it this game does
seem really familiar now I must have
played this either at an arcade or or at
home awesome oh I know I played this in
the arcades definitely so yeah this game
is challenging
like any good arcade game from the late
80s
challenging in that it's just trying to
make you spend as much money as possible
precisely
so have you ever beaten this game no
I've beaten one stage of this game yes
okay
I was playing a little bit to practice
so I have a little bit of an idea what
I'm doing but
so can you do you get to choose your
power ups or is it all just kind of
random yeah you just choose your power
ups uh you cycle through them I only
chose the bombs for now
um so those guys I just drop right there
ah
um [__] so yeah you can see there I took
a little bit of damage okay I took a lot
talking and playing these games
hardest thing in the world okay so as
you can see you have these forces that
are kind of approaching the base those
those trucks and that plane will get
closer and you'll have to actually go
away from missions to stop them from
destroying the base which is kind of I
guess you'd say this story line at hand
and you have an old guy in kind of a
vest yeah he's the mechanic he's the
queue of the of this world it's probably
the only mechanic too like he takes he
seems like he would take care of all of
this it looks kind of crazy just a
little bit and he would destroy the wolf
nice air though that is that's Maxwell
level
it's that kind of front Bob in the front
actually the usual co-host
it's just I my hair is not as luxurious
as
Maxwell's
oh that was a little floating guy was a
power up that you picked up you betcha I
believe that guy is also used another
Capcom game don't remember correctly yes
he looked familiar but you don't get no
matter what your role is just playing in
a ship yes it's a Capcom game isn't
there going to be some kind of crazy
unlockable or like you you play as a
piece of tofu
uh it's not that era of Capcom
you're asking all these questions I'm
gonna die
um yeah there's the the last guy out of
the uh the character selection screen
Greg
he's uh he can take a lot of hits so I
might have to switch to him uh it's
interesting that you have power and you
like you have a life you can actually
get hit and get that life back I know
right which is not it's very atypical
also the UN is like a real dicks for
descending one person to do this
oh no all right I got this
do I yep
all right
that was how much money you spent in
terms of military expenditure no I
earned ninety nine thousand dollars
during that mission
this is just the beginning
yeah uh yeah hold on a minute same
estate
I've got to go back to the main menu
what do you want me to turn down exactly
like the game audio just the volume
itself yeah
all right
cool thank you
I'm not connected to the internet now
the laptop's on though
say that was one of the nice things you
can do about the Retron 5 is you can use
safe States you can hop out change
settings and jump right back in I'm
going to take on
this level right here which ends with a
stealth fighter that I've yet to beat so
if the planes reach area 88 as it just
came over or did they throw you into
that level and you have to play it
they'll throw you into that level
automatically so I'm just kind of
choosing to take them off take them out
first like if I can I'm gonna use all my
weapons here
thank you
keyboard is so tiny wow
this level is just fighting against this
ship uh well yeah you fight against a
bunch of other planes yeah but then you
get to you know like the style fighter
at the end which is clearly an American
also this seems like a very unsafe
flying uh what you're flying in the
middle of a lightning storm yeah I am
video games dude
did your help come back automatically or
are you finding it comes back
automatically but like once you get hit
at first I believe that it takes you
down to three quarters yeah it takes you
down with every successive hit
um
only I had that one month
so you're fighting the boss as you go
along and he just keeps disappearing no
no dude you'll see it yeah
I'm talking like the the real stealth
bomber
your ship is enormous compared to some
of these other smaller Fighters
that doesn't seem very stealthy
really big
switch
foreign
s aren't that difficult but at the same
time
uh I'm still trying to connect to the
internet
this is not my lap this is not my laptop
I this is the laptop which is sitting
here
my laptop
this is excuses
what are some of your favorite Superman
games
Turtles in Time this just looks so good
there were so many games that capture
that 16-bit style that I I think people
still try to capture in some of the the
new indie games
and they just look so good and they I
think they still look really good but
it's something that that holds up well
as whereas some other games like
especially like on 360 or if you go back
to Xbox and PS2 where Brad graphically
games don't hold up as well as maybe
16-bit titles yeah that's Nintendo 64
for me sometimes I have a really hard
time
those Graphics it really depends on the
game and the way that the artists like
use those limitations and making their
assets
I think Eric they fixed everything
uh yeah and the restaurant Flag does
such a good job of making these games
shine
I mean I like playing in a CRT at home I
had one on my desk but at the same time
never ceases to do amazing how good
these games look
bombs
second the Super Nintendo you still had
so many of these really good
third party games like Capcom was
putting up just a lot of really cool
stuff as opposed to the Wii U that we
have now
an apt observation
okay let's get intense especially out of
oh oh you made it yeah cool
foreign
I'm not sure actually
I mean they they obviously have
incredible technology this does seem
like an American type foe because
to the amount of Firepower they're able
to throw at you and you're just a
scrappy one-man fighter yeah but I've
got heart damn it
isn't that what really counts this is
fighting the American imperialists
I don't quite have enough to find any
plans
going to save my state
as I'm a wimp
the same states are really nice they do
give you the opportunity to you know see
the whole game you're not very good at
it
in like as a normal person not someone
who can just
spend all of their time playing one game
for the rest of their life
which one will you use
your plane can handle these weapons
so do you have to stay as Sheen the
entire time yeah during yeah like until
you start a new game you have to use the
same character I'm pretty sure
having never beaten a game I can't say
much
I was never good at these kind of games
like I played some radius
it takes so much practice
don't you have a turbo button shouldn't
you well so what you can do is you can
hold it down it'll fire a certain amount
of shots and bursts and then we'll sort
of reset
but
winners don't use turbo
losers game
shapowi on the stream says the U.N
aren't nearly this effective outside of
video games
and die guy one one two two uh asked if
we're playing on the Retron 5 which we
said earlier yeah this is a Retron five
yes
oh my God these guys are moving up and
down as I move up and down that's
disorienting and difficult to deal with
ah this might make me nauseous
and
other side
so do you do you have everything
unlocked at the beginning it's just the
amount of money that you have to spend
towards it yes so this is going to be a
short stage that that timer is only 35
more seconds
what oh yeah yeah this is the thing that
happens
oh
okay
oh maybe you're supposed to destroy
something yeah I think maybe it would be
that
foreign
this seems like a horrible mission for a
fighter like this
wouldn't you want to call in a bomber
and maybe with a big Crush
Maybe
no bonus
it's cleared in that you survived but
you didn't actually achieve your mission
destroying everything
hitting away is my style
that plane's getting so close how would
you like someone says I remember hating
this Mission without bombs how would you
play that without bombs can you slow
down you're just going the same suit
just going the same speed all right who
should I face here
uh what are the triangles those are just
like the submarines submarine all right
of course planes are the perfect match
for submarines
um the Hirsch says are there any
compatibility issues with the Retron 5
yeah it's not perfect
Street Fighter Alpha two for example did
not work
it worked just fine on Retron 3. that's
one of those games that has like
decompression chips in it and
the problem is that when you load the
cartridge into the Retron 5 it actually
dumps what it sees on the cart the
decompression in Alpha 2 happens between
stages so it actually can't account for
that
um because it only sees what's dumped to
the to the ram of the Retron 5. which is
not the decompress data the submarine
pops out of the water if it's going to
like it's a shark coming out to attack
you
ah there you can see that's all the
submarine has to do to win what don't
come out submarine stay down who's the
guy I told you had a submarine
it seems like someone would say who you
can only hit us when we come up let's
just keep doing that oh I know he's
really good at getting you that thing
I got it I got it no didn't get him
screwed screwed I'm screwed
yeah the un's really gone down they just
have this one ship it seems like you
might want to do some Naval Warfare here
boats or submarines might help
it kind of opens up as it jumps out of
the water like you can see its mouth
it opens up and shoots something at you
I just wanted to die so bad
I mean now it's gone
uh well it's hidden it realized that it
was going you're going to attack those
planes so it went underwater I don't
think you really have to worry about
that getting to area 88 though which
seems in the middle of a desert
yeah you make a good point
maybe it's one of those
those amphibious submarines that
occurred so much
super mega loser says would one be able
to complete the Mega Drive version of
X-Men on Retron 5. does that kind of
stuff work on this it's a good question
uh yeah yeah like I mean the whole
stacking things oh I assume that's what
he means there's no stacking in X-Men
oh so it would just work fine yeah it
should work just fine I don't know that
there's anything special about that cart
um this level sucks best of the hero
said dang Peter stay on the lower left
it won't hit you then who's probably
referring to the uh shark memory
intentional units Bandits coming in
scramble and chase them on level again
I don't think they understand what
Bandits mean because these guys are
actually really well coordinated and
they have a lot of good technology
you're definitely gonna have to switch
to Greg
someone said am I going to be able to
come back and play PaRappa the Rapper
are you gonna play for rapper the rapper
uh I can totally play that on megabit
one day it doesn't work on the Retron 5
though because that's all but totally
yeah I mean
as a game I could play if I want me to
that is a good game I love that game
that's a great one for stream too it's
not that difficult and it's got a lot of
variety but it's hard to talk it's not
one you can have a conversation no no
because the conversation with me
kind of like what you want to say now
yes
shut the [__] up
I'm just kidding all right
did you get any pizza place leaflets to
go with it imminent imminent stranger oh
goody I just got an email catalog oh
they're just having weird conversations
that's not about this I didn't get my
Avon catalog yet I look forward to
Victoria's Secret catalogs
it's the game not you
these Bandits man well and they have
like tiger striped planes wow yeah oh
God they're so good at going see this
guy behind me I feel like he should be
on my team oh yeah wow what a jerk
they're firing at you
they're really bad at fighting you I'm
pretty bad at finding them to be fair I
mean they're just
it seems like if he comes up behind you
yeah he would be a friendly he's kind of
colored like you because all the other
guys have tiger stripes uh ships
those Bandits man
that's a really cool effect though with
the clouds didn't move up and down I
don't like it because the planes move
too like there's no way that they could
react that fast
oh yeah it doesn't make sense whoa
oh that's such [__] I got hit maybe
once
and that you can't go backwards like
that they're coming from behind you
they're coming from basically every
direction yeah
yeah we're gonna start over with Greg
uh
necrotron says I don't think I remember
ever beating this game but I remember
playing the early levels a lot
it's a lot like my experience
so much damage so much damage
but this has so it's an arcade game I
would assume you could probably beat it
pretty quickly once you once you're good
at it there's I don't know uh no I don't
believe it's that long of the game it's
just really difficult
does the Retron 5 let you turn on cheat
codes yes it does actually it might be
fun to dive into the game genius
we're supposed to get around that how am
I supposed to deal with that
chase them off what's on his forehead
why does he have a X on his forehead
he's really serious all the time it's
like a burrowed brow you have one of
those to do unfortunately like a just a
deep crevice I guess it's like a crevice
in between my eyebrows a valley yeah
it's like a valley of stress you watch
Peter while he's playing this you'll be
able to see the valley form between his
eyes it's true dude it grows
my girlfriend is very aware when it
happens
what are you worried about
oh you're doing much better this time
switch nope not to that to this
yeah he's a bandit now
let's kill you guys
what I can't do what purple
again not not super stealthy maybe it's
just kind of a radar thing purple
doesn't show up on radar
and then you're gonna play as Greg
I'm super excited I'm embarrassingly bad
at video games
112 says someone speed run this game
well you can't really speedrun it
because it kind of I mean I guess maybe
you could at those timed levels but it
Scrolls forward automatically I guess if
you don't die versus dying without
yeah I don't know I bet you there's one
out there I'm sure there's a great tool
assistant speed run on YouTube
I would love to see someone beat this in
one client now someone says the game
takes about half an hour to beat Master
the hero
you could probably beat the game twice
fortunately we're video game
professionals
is it is he walking on water it looked
like
the flooding in this area is ferocious
and this is on easy this is uneasy
just a reminder I forgot
yeah thanks
all right Greg Gates
the controller's nice and warm and
primed up for you it's like when you sit
down in somebody's seat and it's warm
and you're like oh that's oh this is
gross I kind of like it's all clammy
uh so okay so you use this button to
fire you can hold down this button to
use your special weapons and this one to
cycle through your special weapons
Target is the front line base take it
and make it our sword for thorning
project four I'd like to give things
numbers
oh
you don't even give you you have to pay
for a ship yeah dude I know he's on he's
on your side he's like look let's be
honest here I'm only in this for the
money
I don't really care which nation wins
give me that money
I'll take this
it's not cluster I don't have enough
money
sorry you and Guy
I'm a contractor oh [__] I used one
if you hold it down yeah you kind of
have to you hold it down for a second or
two and then just start building it down
again
what if you're like a un Squadron
prodigy
what if you get elected into the United
Nations
because you're so good at us
maybe this was a testing ground for U.N
Pilots
it's like one of those code cracking
games yeah totally all right so these
guys are firing at you from the ground
they're gonna have like a big brother
that's going to fire [__]
oh he fires everywhere
there you go good use yeah
when can I power up my weapon there we
go
luckily it does stick with you stage to
Stage like this game has so many crushes
for players that so many other shooting
games don't have
it's still dark it's awesome you can
shoot those little ones
get together Greg
Justin is Greg
got him and Tank's on fire
uh eminent stranger this is actually
720P
okay you can tell by looking at it
how many peas there are yeah we've also
got scan lines turned on for some reason
um yeah why don't we change the here
before we do anything let's change the
graphical filter just for the fun of it
off
super super eagle you want Super Eagle
what does that even mean
what is even a super eagle
does that mean something to you is that
like some these are different types of
filters right so they'll take the pixels
down
oh this looks kinda
iosi
the target is a battleship oh I don't
have a oh you just it chose four I think
maybe it happened when I pressed down
and started to get to the menu
I like how it shows you hear the other
ships you can't buy uh yeah necrotron
there is no input lag with the Retron 5.
um
it's one of the great Parts about it
actually because not everyone has a CR
TV CRT TV and hooking up you know old
school consoles HDTV does create that
lag which when the threshold for success
is so tiny
control games it's kind of a pain in the
ass as we saw a few times such as on
Donkey Kong Country when I played that
Minecart level
I don't know I think me and Max over
intern Max played that like
like 120 times and you could not beat it
and yes I still blame him for lag to
this day
oh my phone started
I guess you can turn on turbo if you
want if you do have a turbo
oh you're dead
I keep wanting to push the rnl to switch
weapons yeah
we could actually configure it that way
pink button
all right we're gonna go to Quick ad
break stay with us we'll be right back
for more megabit and un Squadron
all right
foreign
so we've decided that even though we're
really really awesome at this game oh
yeah maybe it would be even more fun to
unlock lots of extra money and buy all
of the things so let's uh let's see if
we can't we're gonna have to go into the
Retron 5 menu here so this is built into
the Retron 5. I feel like I'm a Salesman
when I say something like that I know
but this thing is really cool right so
there's kind of
oh I don't have the SD card with the
cheats what yeah so the cheats are
stored on the SD card in like a database
file
it's not in the system right now
oh so you can't so we're just gonna have
to show you guys how good we are and
just keep playing
uh do you wanna if you can load up one
of the other save states we've got in
there if you head down and start
and then go to load state
or do it again but hit the a button
instead of
loaded snapshot
get what this is with your crappy
fighter not mine but
hey is able to withstand
so this is where you fight that worm
from that movie Tremors seriously no I
wish I would believe you it's the desert
oh you don't know in fact Tremors was a
documentary
about your life about your life
I grew up in Kentucky
I grew up in Connecticut ah what are the
blue things uh that upgrades
your shot upgrade your shot
helicopter has just been waiting oh
do I just have shitty guns why does it
not just do anything because it's a
helicopter dude
what's the red Power up to uh Power
something up
probably your health I imagine I don't
know unfortunately I don't have the
manual for this game
oh
just flew right into that
select your target area
Jeeps have we found Jeep chat
uh yeah so that was the one where we had
to blow up the the thing
uh someone's asking what we're running
on again this is on the Retron 5.
oh you almost have enough for the F20
I see that no you need those followers
you got the
oh this is
when you fly back tap
watch out for that rock yeah
oh you gotta hit oh yeah
good bombs
you have to deploy all of them
individually go go go go
you can use a mega one too if you switch
with X real quick
yeah use that
right now
push back yeah
no bonus
maybe if you gave me a bomber better
ship
I guess so Master the hero is saying we
should just eat the damage from The Rock
and just sail out of the ground to shoot
the base oh yeah I guess that just makes
sense yeah
Pro tip
I got another truck
pretty manageable that was fun
see we can get more money to unlock
you're playing yeah I bet you one more
oh wait oh yeah okay so one more and
we'll be able to unlock something
maybe if I get the bonus this time
yeah the cluster could work too but
might as well not waste money
Lizzy says I've never seen a no bonus
before whoa I pushed the wrong button
yeah so good as low as possible
I don't know it doesn't seem like the
best strategy to me yeah that actually
just got pushed upwards but it caught on
the stage for a little bit
stinks if you've never seen no bonus
wait till you see us die in the bonus
stage
all right get low get low
wait not yet you're gonna die okay Get
Low
no bonus
yeah we that that actually didn't get us
anything yeah man I hate to make you
make excuses
but if Justin had been playing
I don't I don't know about this filter
let's try another filter this is all
right so hit
that's bad
you want to try Super Eagle yeah I'm
gonna get your superhero on
yeah they don't they don't change a
whole lot it's kind of just the way that
the pixels get reorganized
uh scale 2x is pretty good that
basically takes a native resolution and
bumps it up a little bit yeah uh I don't
know about good
lq2x
uh
uh all right I'm gonna try
I'm not gonna get
I think we took good care of all the
trucks there are no more trucks
destroy their supply lines
it would be nice if there was some kind
of RPG element to it where like if you
destroy the trucks then the same thing
has changed after that yeah like the
planes just kind of fall out of the sky
like oh we ran out of fuel you destroyed
our Convoy
I really like the plane animations
when they when they turn around yeah
and give up on fighting you God damn it
see look you're walking on the ocean I
think it's supposed to be like the
desert
still
fight the shark Marine what if I just
sip it
see that
uh super mega loser says Peter used to
be really good at GameStop
one of these days I wanted to do a
stream where I'm like not engaging with
anyone
to me like laser focus
maybe it's not talking just not talking
maybe it would make a difference maybe
it wouldn't make any difference
it helps to to not
you know from going to to lots of game
demos when you're like playing with
developers both the developers
themselves usually tries to get someone
else to play the game so that they can
talk to you right but then there's
always that point where they hand you
the controller you're still talking to
them yeah so you're like I I can try to
talk or I can play this game well
thank you oh now I want to write the
movie shark Marine
it's about a submarine that's fused with
the DNA of a shark
and the military thinks this is a great
idea but then the shark gets its own
ideas and becomes a shark Marine because
and then it starts eating nuclear subs
and like continues to grow and then it's
and everyone in like New York is
freaking out even though it can't it's
too big to get in there and so the movie
doesn't really make sense from that way
but it's like oh no the shark Green's
heading for New York
and then of the the world scrambled Jets
to fight it because that makes sense
because you can't fight you can't find a
shark Marine with submarines because
it'll just eat them
obviously obviously
pillars of fire shoot
I like the latest military technology
these guys have a lot of technology and
like they're just throwing so much
Firepower at you but it seems very
misguided
all right I'm gonna fight the bomber
oh oh no [__]
why is there a button that you just
shuts it off without asking you do you
want to do that
cancel cancel
all right I got the F20
that's a horrible placement for a power
button where it's right where you grab
it it's like when you pick up the laptop
like oh there's a power button let me
just shut everything down
all right dude I got new weapons here oh
wow those are this is for the F20 the
six that looks like a laser guided
missile
oh so the weapons are based on your
plane it skims over the ground
it locks on the enemies
I'm gonna do this that
is what is this
I'm going all out what do I have to lose
except mine
now you have 200 and I'm not going to
remember what any of these do and I'm
going to cycle through them oh it's this
is it like
um
Who Wants To Be A Millionaire like is
there a point where you can just say
like you know I'm good you win you you
guys deal with it I I'm gonna take my
weddings and go home yeah
it's playing so far
Federate managing is [__]
okay don't need the Falcon in this level
whatsoever
ah
good thing you got bumps and skim along
the ground
shut up
that's helpful
okay
I don't I don't actually use twitch oh
um it should pop out in a second here we
go
yeah I've exhausted a lot of my money
you don't get it back like
but you get to keep the ship that you
bought right
yeah
yeah just not the weapons
like is that
the cluster Fire Bomb thing looks really
awesome
seems like they would just should give
that to you at the beginning
I don't think he really has a vested
interest in you winning
yeah no kidding he has a vested interest
in making a [__] ton of cash off of me
off my repeated deaths
just died I want these planes around me
to just go away just go away how about
that how about give up go home
let me save the world
that's so much
it's so lame how they hang back behind
you but you don't have a way of firing
upwards or downwards you can't fly
behind them
like this this level would make more
sense if you could fly backwards
yeah or if I could shoot backwards at
least
but no matter what you're stuck within
this
confines of the stage so they can
basically back you into a corner of the
sky
as you as they're doing repeatedly
oh just die just die no one likes you at
least of all the UN
they're really pretty though those are
like stylish ships
it's all about fashion the [__] gets
kind of green
oh yes
oh my God
that's why Wireless was being weird
oh here comes the submarine being a dick
again
oh it probably has long range missiles
that it doesn't use against you but it
has them
we gotta go all out I gotta do it
and I'm going to save my state here
that's a good idea thank you
I forgot that you could do that
I think I found a wife I think I can
yeah you hacking the internet uh no I'm
just using Republic Wi-Fi I can't get
the private one to work
but that's fine
technology
now we're back in chat if you ask
something important and we didn't answer
it it's because I'm an idiot
and you can ask again now
this level would be a lot less fun but
it would make more sense if it was just
the submarine shooting missiles up at
you and the only thing you can do is die
and then after that the message so like
just a message pops up on screen that
goes sometimes failure is the only
option
like oh thanks game
all right I think I stand a chance
as long as I
stop getting shot jackass
right as I said that
okay so you already bought everything
you have all of the weapons I have all
of the weapons
I'm gonna make a crush this guy
I'm a submarine
shark Marine
part Marine all shark
yeah I guess that doesn't make sense
because sharks are all already kind of
marine
so is there a way on the Retron 5 to
lock slow things down
no you can speed things up on the NES
though
Lizzy says it's a cheater right now
always start with a mega Crush for a
moss oh for a boss
she's misspellback
You misspelled something
no no they didn't oh you just don't know
how to read
oh needing his part
that old Melody oh so you put on another
filter right no that's what the that's
the lqx
like looking at the character you
probably can't see it in the video I
don't know how high quality it is
that was quick
You Wanna Give a shot
it's nice and warm again do you want to
lose
cool we got to save state
and you have 15 minutes to beat this
freaking Marine shark submarine sandwich
hole pump
oh
welcome
that's the one that uh yeah it's good
here
oh yeah he's gonna come up he's in the
rear he's in a rear
oh no
danger danger
ah oh thank you slow down that helped so
much
ah it wasn't for that slow down I'd be
dead
anyway
uh press down and start and then use the
a button to load state
all right so I think you're onto
something there by going over to the
right hand side of the screen you know
because the missiles were all focused on
yeah to the left yeah
thanks
be careful be careful now I'm old
like a crush
or Pal I didn't even know I didn't see
what the stuff at the top of the screen
was what's pal pow prisoner of war how
many prisoners of War we've captured or
how many we have no it's just like it's
your power level which honestly if it's
below 9000 it's not even worth talking
about
oh that hurt me
let me see I'm gonna try
with our combined knowledge of
how to play and where to go on screen I
think we can do this
oh so Lizzy says just so you know when
you're flashing and in danger oh you get
hit again you die it doesn't matter how
much health yeah
use the boosters happy there's nothing
wrong with our G diffuser
yes
yeah I feel like the bomb's up a lot
here especially when they miss
oh no I gotta get out of here must not
die
careful now yeah thanks this game would
be a lot less fun without the shape
state
you can see you still have three chances
super mega loser says some closing the
stream is bad mojo
Seb will leave the stream unbeaten
[__]
I say maybe oh yeah so sivrev 2 was
announced today someone else mentioned
and but it's only coming to mobile and
iOS
it's like that's where the industry is
going or something
how do you feel about that Peter
I'm not a fan of a series that people
love in one venue into another because
money but hey that's business right for
worse
it gives more people the opportunity to
play it and maybe
but let's be honest no real sip fan is
going to want to play that on mobile
maybe they'll accept it and do it but no
one's going to be happy about it it
could do a good job there are lots of
good mobile games sure if you're not
willing to consider this might also be a
bad idea oh no it could be terrible
especially if they put in like some
energy or
they would too you can play for 20
minutes a day pay five dollars for extra
wood
I feel like we could beat this I feel
like we're going to beat this
this seems very doable
don't die oh [__] that was a terrible
joke then
yeah no she did my mom's alive oh so
she's doable oh yeah
oh
I just don't want to die anymore
like I feel like that's not asking too
much
I mean it's I'm partially responsible
for all the death
to be honest
I'm not sure those are more powerful I
know
oh you got a regular bombs and I've got
11 laughs
because I feel like that's you can do
you shoot more of them at least
on an hour
all right dude so close yeah but my
bones but we're also almost out of
actual good I don't want to hear it
don't want to hear it oh oh
you can feel it
they did a really good job we should
really get them working for you
don't quite submarine anymore
you're gonna make it I think we got this
although you're constantly in danger oh
[__]
Steve is going to take all of the
Firepower
if you could just get that armor on your
ship
it'd be much more effective one man army
and considering that they're throwing
hundreds of ships at you
like let's give you a ship that you know
you can probably take out in two hits
with like their weakest weapon
but for you
if you throw everything you have
including this nuclear missile that we
fire into the air that's still not
enough
should be you should be able to win
right
should be able to
I think you have the pattern now though
it feels like this
this is probably the win this is what we
want
a two dollars for archery
oh yeah
at least they only send one fighter
every time it launches
yeah it could be a lot worse
that one guy is willing to die I'm kind
of curious now to see what this is like
on hard do you just die faster or
are there like five planes to come out
how is the difficulty balance good
question
like this
I'm back again with those missiles I
thought he was done with those
you think you'd run out enough he has he
has an infinite ammo oh yeah see tight
all you haters in the chat
about going out strong with a sub a
shark Marine win whew
and a bonus and a bonus
and
we're not complete [__] at this game
well you're not I
you don't mess with the best so someone
says on hard the bullets move faster and
there's a few more enemies
sweet
now you get to tuckle the guy with a
furrowed brow and really nice pants just
the nicest slacks you've ever seen
they're tight
it's very fashionable for sending people
off to die going all out
because it's probably the last mission
someone said Master the hero says the
bonus is more of a refund
I go Crush
that's the way to follow this up with
not only a win against a submarine but a
bonus in the Convoy
um
so after firing 20 missiles you hit it
once
yeah 95
hundredths of a second
that's almost a second you round that up
wait a second left yeah let's round that
up why not
is that before you run out of fuel and
your ship crashes I don't know why is
there a time limit on fighting the
Convoy they're not getting away they're
sandwiched between two rocks yeah
they're basically immobile
it's pretty good to go out in a high
note how much more time do we have uh we
got about two three minutes ah so we're
gonna go out on a load that we're gonna
go out on fail what no don't say that
all right well that way well now you
know the game obviously now I'm just
gonna beat it backwards and forwards
I'll probably beat it in the next one
upside down and inside out
for the world what you're all about yeah
I was hoping to see some of these other
weapons you have to make it we have to
make the point of getting uh getting the
SD card to get the game genie unlocked
goals I know actually these kind of
games yeah I usually I don't know why
it's not in there I wonder where it went
because not only is that the way that I
prefer to play games I would rather
watch someone the Kick-Ass yes
absolutely right there with you there's
nothing like a stream where like you
suddenly realize 10 minutes in that
not only did you know you were bad
before but in terms of streaming you
can't even
do it like all right we're gonna spend
the next 45 minutes slowly unlocking
each weapon
you should have seen when we were doing
a Donkey Kong stream it was really bad
it's probably the worst
oh look another Convoy
man Lizzy's claiming that your regular
weapon is the best for convoys but every
time we hit that rock it would just send
us
in a bad place right
yeah and we just don't have what it
takes
I would agree with that
all right it's gonna be our last run
through Justin it's up to you to save
the UN
oh yeah so that might be something all
right Lizzy yes correct you are using
your regular weapon just don't hit the
rock is the lesson
like that
I already have it
it doesn't matter how much damage you
take because
it's all reset
like none of that matters it hit us up
all that money let's do one more actual
level because that was pretty quick
thanks for the tip Lizzy why didn't you
tell us that an hour ago
this information would have been helpful
yesterday or the u.net oh the regular
weapons we've been just spending our
money on crap weapons the desert there's
water and then there's foreign
because
we can manage it
go
yeah it's Kamikaze my way into the
down good
oh that one piece of [__]
that's all
special weapon none
I want to see you out on a big level
though by that I mean I want to watch
you die
I can do that
hidden away is my everyone's style is
hitting away
I'll do that I know to the desert yeah
the desert might be possible
okay
ground carrier
yeah not enough for anything better
but enough for all the weapons
just like this stream see the sun
setting in the background
Rising
not really sure which way is east or
west Justin if you would nominate a game
for me to play next week what would it
be that's PaRappa the Rapper
is that what it's going to be that would
be a good choice that's what's going to
be then
officers
my favorite is the driving lessons
section
so please don't ask
yeah wow oh this gun is so much better
than the ones before
well having lots more weapons unlocked
is
whoa
danger danger
always says that second second round
nose dive
oh there's a boss background yeah I
think there's always that pause where
like you know we'll give you a second to
breathe even though whoa this is
different freaking land carrier
that's normal
what
is it wrong that I have faith in you
that faith is terribly misplaced
oh no
oh
yeah let me give it one shot before we
go sorry guys in the back I know they're
they're pissed me right now
I wish I knew of Will Robinson who was
in danger
why why was that programmed to feel pain
so the Phoenix is the ground one no
that's the [__] yeah oh that's super
it's super effective against tanks yeah
a level that it's that weapon team is
made for
I really like the models on these
and the tanks and the ship though it's a
really cool
a lot of laughter going on back there
I don't like it
I felt like I learned a lot about myself
on the street you know I feel like I
learned a lot about you too
and I even cut my pants off
it's a rarity trust me
what other games would be good for
megatives
I know Tom really wants to do co-op
lemmings
I was never really a big lemon span so
I'm not really sure how it would Fair as
a co-op report
it'd be good to have someone who knows
what they're doing it's able to bring
you along
well Tom Tom knows yeah so
oh well unscathed yeah not a scratch
your pal was at Max your pow
can I only hit it when apparently
I don't know what that did oh that
refilled all your Falcons
all right that's gonna do it we're done
uh thanks for sticking with us everyone
through our failures and minor successes
Justin thank you for joining me mostly
failures mostly failures uh come back
next week for more megabit where we are
going to play PaRappa the Rapper
apparently maybe you'll make a comeback
huh
and then come back at 2PM today for
multiple players of Chris Waters who's
playing a game with some of his friends
I'm not sure what it is but come back
and watch it'll be great it'll be a game
all right take care everyone